what's going on people today we're
continuing to theorize what it would be
like if there was a tense shift in
attack on titan specifically one that
could rival the colossal although the
two of them would be massively different
in size this tense shifter would have
certain abilities that would put them in
nearly the same league at the very least
it'd be a closer match up compared to
the attack titan before we get into it
though don't forget to smash that sub
button if you haven't already and be
sure to check out my playlist in the
description where i break down potential
new titan concepts
okay so to explain this new shifter the
first thing we need to do is flash back
to chapter 112. up until that chapter we
knew that the past connecting all
aldeans could be used to transfer
various things including memories but in
this conversation aaron reveals
something else according to him acumens
who've awakened their potential are able
to inherit the battle experience of
their ancestors inheriting that
experience is presumably what makes them
so skillful in pretty much everything
they attempt and it's a trait that none
of the nine titans possess
this info serves as the foundation for
creating the blast titan because if a
shifter could directly inherit
experience like this then it would
instantly change a lot of things for
example if marley had this titan then my
guess is they start looking for aliens
like mr lionheart who come from
different parts of the world and are
skilled in their own fighting techniques
as we know subject mere exist in
virtually all corners of the globe so
with mali's resources they could find
subjects of emir from different cultures
could be skilled in everything from
regular boxing to sumo wrestling by
turning these people into titan shifters
every new user of the blast titan would
have their own specific fighting style
which would then be added on to by the
next person until eventually you have
this invincible machine that just can't
be beaten in hand-to-hand combat this
ties in nicely to its next ability which
is that the blast heinz physical
strength will continue to grow during
the 13 years the user possesses it what
this means in reality is that when a
person first inherits the shifter
they'll have a base level of power
similar to the beast titan but as the
monsoon years go on its strength will
progressively keep increasing the speed
at which it increases would depend on
how active the user is but generally
speaking this shifter would start to
reach its peak at around 9 years old by
that point it should be able to easily
jump over 60 meters high and probably
even higher than that and would be able
to knock down the colossal if they put
everything into it the power to jump
this high also has another benefit as
it's the core element of this shifter's
most destructive move
to put it simply this signature attack
involves the blast titan launching
itself as high as it can possibly go and
then after curling up into a ball this
18 meter shifter crashes directly into
his target the target in question could
be another titan in which case that
person is most likely gonna die or on
the other hand the target might just be
the ground itself a shifter of this size
would almost be like a small asteroid
crashing into earth with the impact
creating a blast of wind strong enough
to wipe out an entire town
the destructive potential of this move
would be especially bad if it took place
in a highly populated area which is why
i said in the intro that it's nearly in
the same league as the colossal however
the drawback here is that the blastine
has low levels of stamina so although it
is capable of these insane feats of
strength it's not something that can be
done consistently on a good day the
shifter would need at least 30 minutes
to recover before doing something like
this again and as the user themselves
starts to get old the recovery time can
increase to as long as two hours
during that recovery time it'd still be
able to fight in hand-to-hand combat but
the super-powered staff would be
completely off limits this is a natural
way of not allowing his titan to become
too overpowered and it'd also mean the
user would need to be tactical in
deciding when to use its full potential
now moving on to design the helmet on
the blast iron's head is there to
protect its brain from the impact while
in the present day it will protect from
anti-time bullets as well i'd imagine
the smaller cannons wouldn't be able to
break through this thing even at close
range although when it comes to the
larger ones they probably would be able
to break through but i'd still think it
would take two or three hits before it
could crack
despite that this helmet would still
have another more spiritual use which
involves protecting the shifter in a
different way as long as the helmet is
on users of the blast titan become
immune from the influence of the founder
in a pretty much identical way to the
acumens this means the user's memories
can't be controlled or messed with while
they're in the titan form and his body
also can't be altered by the coordinate
which is a big contrast to other
shifters
this level of telepathic resistance
would essentially make the founding
titan and the blast titan natural
enemies as it's incapable of being
manipulated and has the physical
strength to stand against virtually
anything
from that point of view i think it's
fair to say that users of the attacked
item would be pretty good candidates for
this shifter as it would objectively
have the most potential to stand against
the founder
anyhow some final details i wanted to
clear up about this titan include its
stats the number of transformations it
can make and how exactly it grows in
physical strength starting with that
last point the idea behind this is that
it would gradually inherit the power of
the previous users similar to how it
also inherits their fighting instincts
of course the key difference is that the
instincts would be inherited almost
immediately while the physical strength
would take years to fully kick in the
reason for this is that number one i
thought it would be cool to have a titan
that actually grows in strength
alongside its user and number two
gaining its full power up front could
potentially be risky to me it makes more
sense for a person to slowly build their
way up to that level of strength but to
be fair i guess the counter argument
would be that the users of the colossal
gain even more strength pretty much
straight away in terms of how many
transformations it can make for the
first seven or eight years the blast
titan should be able to manifest twice a
day after about a decade its stamina
would then naturally begin to decrease
with one transformation per day becoming
the new limit which is ironic because
around this age is when the shifter
would physically be at its strongest
lastly when it comes to stats overall it
would have a 7 out of 10 for durability
a 10 out of 10 for power 5 out of 10 for
speed 8 out of 10 for resistance to the
founder and 12 out of 10 for combat
ordinarily i would have left combat at
11 out of 10 but when looking into the
official guidebook annie's female titan
has 11 so i figured it needed to at
least be slightly higher than that when
we compare the blast titan stats to the
other shifters it also matches up pretty
well as it'd be the second strongest
behind the colossal but would lose to
the armored when it comes to speed and
durability
ultimately if this tenth titan was in
this series it'd definitely be one of
the most valuable although strategically
speaking it'll also be the only shifter
that khan reaches full potential until
nearly a decade after being inherited
let me know in the comments down below
what you think of this titan concept and
also which side do you think would have
used it better as always thank you for
watching this video and if you liked it
don't forget to check out my playlist in
the description until the next one peace
out